we think of it as pure but according to
the World Health Organization the water
we drink comes with an added extra tiny
often microscopic fragments of plastic
and no one knows whether our health is
at risk here we can just about see some
very small specks and we suspect that
those are the might the plastics
scientists at Cranfield University have
studied drinking water in Britain and
helped write the w-h-o report while tap
water is believed to contain between
zero and ten plastic particles in every
liter bottled water can contain hundreds
bottled water is a little bit different
because we're talking about containing
water in a plastic container with a
plastic cap and there has been a number
of studies that have looked at mica
plastics in bottled water and it does
seem to be that there are higher levels
of mica plastics in bottled water when
you compare that to the limited number
of studies that there are on tap water
around 350 million tonnes of plastic
produced each year micro plastics are
created by wear and tear dust and
fragments breaking off everything from
car tires to clothing and even paint the
fragments are found in our food
contaminate the air we breathe and are
washed into the sea they are everywhere
imagine Napa
studies micro plastics research
supported by sky ocean rescue it's how
do you remove something that's that fool
that's the problem
she says the World Health Organization's
report underlines the need for action we
really live in the plastic age and there
are benefits to it but we really need to
rein in our plastic use and we don't
need items like bananas wrapped in
plastic when they already have a potato
layer the big question now is what
happens to micro plastics inside the
human body the World Health Organization
says the smallest particles are likely
to be absorbed and although the evidence
so far suggests the health risks are
likely to be minimal scientists can't be
sure in the report calls for more
research the sky' sponsored boat turned
the tide on plastic found particles as
remote as the Southern Ocean while
taking part in a row
the world raised but microplastic is
also in our drinking water isn't a
surprise the scientists are now
scrambling to understand the
implications Thomas More Sky News